I stopped drinking and I just put the
weight off was there an incident this
was about 20
things you know that you have a drinking
problem when the bartender knows your
name and you've never been to that bar
before I was walking through New York
and I've gotten into the whiskey that
night and I was listening to my
headphones this guy in a Jag cut me off
when I was cut Crossing uh lllo Street I
hit the car as hard as I can with my
hands you know I just keep walking tap
on my shoulder about 20 seconds later
two 6' 6 guys they both at the same time
spit my face and they walked away and I
remember reaching into a trash can and
grabbing a beer bottle and saying to
myself out loud nobody spits in Zach
galanakis his face threw the beer bottle
at the car and it
missed and that's my story yeah